so Beth what do you make the results in
so far well Anna we've got about a
quarter of the results in and how will
we look framing it last night was number
one it's a box office set of local
elections because it's the first big
electoral test or the last one rather
before the general election there were
three things we were looking for can
Labor uh do they look like they're on
course to uh becoming uh the party of
government and could care starmer win an
outright majority it's an absolute huge
ask by the way to have to have a bigger
swing than Tony Blair did in 1997 and
that was a post-war record just to put
it in context of the scale of that task
the second question or the sub you know
the subplot in all of it was the the lib
Dem blue wall Battleground and then the
third thing was can Rishi sunak contain
conservative party losses has he is some
of the strategists say uh detoxified or
beginning to detoxify
um the brand and on all of these frogs
the result results are genuinely
fascinating and are really telling a
interesting and Illuminating story about
where the country's at and if I if I
start off with labor I mean it was a
terrible night for the Tories and I'll
come to that
um they have made wins in key councils
so far it's early still that they've
never won before like Medway and Kent so
that was a huge symbolic moment Tony
Blair didn't win Medway uh but but Kia
starma has they're looking to take Dover
and Swindon in the red wall uh they took
Stoke on Trent what will they uh what
will we see in Middlesbrough and
Darlington but
the caveat here is they didn't pick up
as much as we might have thought in
Hartlepool and Tamworth and in Dudley in
the West Midlands and also I heard
overnight that in the East Midlands this
is a key Battleground between the
conservatives and labor that it might be
a bit softer there for them so could we
see a little bit of loss of momentum
later in the day but I think it's pretty
clear that what we're seeing is they're
heading uh for a general election win
the big question is can they win an
overall majority you've had them all
spinning here this morning going oh well
yes we can Michael Thrasher our election
expert and I tend to trust him more than
a political spinner is saying the jury
is still out on that but again it goes
backhanded to that question about it
being a gigantic task so that's labor on
the lib Dems I mean an absolutely
barnstorming performance for them and
coming from a high Watermark when they
contested these seats back in in 20 2019
we were saying a gains of over 150 were
incredible a senior figure in the party
has suggested to me that they might hit
gains of 300 or more so this is going to
be a big story today the fight in the
blue wall and these seats we haven't
really seen them contested in well
certainly last year's local election so
it's the fast acid test really about how
are the Tories holding up in the remain
facing parts of the blue wall and the
answer is they are not and the libdam
said to me today as they won Windsor and
maidenhead the worst is yet to come for
the conservatives Surrey Hertfordshire
uh Sussex alts counting shortly and then
finally to come to Rishi sooner a
disappointing night well back in 2019
when labor and the Tories did really
badly in this set of local elections we
described it as a plague on both your
houses there was a rejection of both the
conservatives and the labor party
remember it was brexit Wars Theresa May
soon lost her job Boris Johnson came in
and then that Barn storm in general
election this this is not a plague on
both your houses this is a plague on
Tory houses I mean they are losing in
the red wall they are losing in the blue
wall uh it shows as their Rivals have
said that the country is telling the
conservatives that they are fed up with
them and what does it mean for Rishi
soon at because he was meant to be the
person that smoothed over some of the
bad recent memories if you like of the
trust mini budget and and all the
debacle around Boris Johnson but it's
suggesting that he's not picking up any
support at all now if they get losses
over 700 seats it's going to be to quote
one senior Insider an absolute disaster